hey guys I'm out of the country but we
didn't want to leave you hanging with no
good news so here's something positive
that happened
hello
good evening my name is Liam Morrison I
live where I'm street I'm in the seventh
tenth grade at Nichols Middle School I
appreciate the opportunity to speak to
you today I never thought that the shirt
I wore to school on March 21st would
lead me to speak with you today on that
Tuesday morning I was sticking out of
gym class to sit down with two adults
for what turned out to be a very
uncomfortable talk I was told that
people were complaining about the words
on my shirt that my shirt was making
some students feel unsafe yes rose on a
shirt made people feel unsafe they told
me that I wasn't in trouble but it sure
felt like I was I told I was told that I
would need to remove my shirt before I
could return to class when I nicely told
them that I didn't want to do that they
called my father thankfully my dad
supported my my decisions came to pick
me up what did my shirts say five simple
words there are only two genders nothing
harmful nothing threatening just a
statement I believe to be a fact I have
been told that my shirt was targeting a
protect active class who is this
protected class are their feelings more
important than my rights I don't
complain when I see pride flags and
diversity posters hung throughout the
school do you know why because others
have a right to their beliefs just as I
do not one person staff or student told
me that they were bothered by what I was
wearing actually just the opposite
several kids told me that they supported
my actions and that they wanted one too
I experienced wait a minute I was told
that the shirt was A disruption to
learning no one got up and stormed out
of class no one burst into tears I'm
sure I would have noticed if they had I
experienced disruptions to my learning
every day kids acting out in class are A
disruption yet nothing is done why did
the rules apply to one yet not another I
feel like these adults were telling me
that it wasn't okay for me to have an
opposing view their arguments were weak
in my opinion I didn't go to school that
day to hurt feelings or cause trouble I
have learned a lot from this experience
I learned that a lot of other students
share my view I learned that adults
don't always do the right thing or make
the right decisions I know that I have a
right to wear those fight a shirt with
those five words even at 12 years old
they have my own political opinions and
I have a right to express those opinions
even at school this right is called the
First Amendment to the Constitution
My Hope in being here tonight is to
bring the school committee's attention
to this issue I hope that you will speak
up for the rest of us so we can express
ourselves without being pulled out of
class next time it may not only be me
there might be more students that decide
to speak out thank you for your time and
good night